Hear me out. >> God, dude, everything about the way she
moves just screams pretentious [__] [laughter] [__]
>> That's so awesome. >> Oh my god, what if I use
my microphone and people are
>> Seriously, like how do you hate women this much that
this is a thing?
Do we want to go to this Pokimane rage bait thing?
Dude, people are so mad about this. It's
I don't How does How does Poki keep um How does she keep baiting
people like
She just so perfectly nails it for everybody every time. Bro,
she she talked about how people were nicer in video games. I
know what she's talking about, but I'm Listen, I'm I'm going
to hit this from a different incel angle,
All right, so what does she say? Pokimane on how gaming online
has changed for women in the past 10 to 15 years. People were
actually so nice. Would gift you free stuff. Now I feel like
girls are a little bit scared to always been some issues and
Why Is Arc having a stroke while he's typing this?
>> I
read this random little Tik Tok where I was talking about how
Hear me out. Do you guys remember like
10 No, 10 15 years ago? I feel like 10 15 years ago if you were
a girl gaming online,
people were actually so nice to you. Like so nice. They treated
you so well. >> They would gift you free stuff. All >> That's
like the indication that she's referring to a very specific kind
of thing, okay? She's not referring to like general behavior.
You get into a lobby cuz if you don't remember 10 15 years ago,
you didn't really have lobbies the same way. You didn't really
like queue into games.
There were dedicated servers. There's nothing or there was like
overworld or something, right? Like RuneScape kind of There was
no There's no like um like queuing into stuff and meeting people
for the first time like repeatedly over and over. It just didn't
happen as much. >> stuff. Do you guys remember?
But nowadays, I feel like girls are a little bit scared to game
online or to use their mic or whatever. Mac, do you remember
saying?
I just like sometimes I think about these days and I'm like I
I'm not hallucinating that, right? >> get on.
>> But that's the thing. It makes me sad for maybe like
younger women who just got into gaming and they think that this
is just how it's been all the time, but
not so much the case, I don't think. I mean, don't get me wrong.
There's >> I What I think it is is she probably gamed like
early on when she was younger, okay?
And one of two things happened. Either a tried to groom her or
or it's just it was a supply and demand thing, okay? 10-15 years
ago, there just were almost no women playing games, especially
not young women, okay? So, there was just no women playing games.
If you were actually a girl and you would get on TeamSpeak or
something,
it would be like over, okay? People would be trying to get your
attention all the time. It was just a supply and demand thing.
Uh I don't even know if was League out 10 years ago?
of Legends.
When did League come out? 2009? Really?
Am I old?
What the [__] I was thinking Pokémon like met some
people. She became like a TeamSpeak person, and then she just
got free stuff gifted to her. She's definitely like a proto-Discord
queen, and that's what she remembers. That was her existence
online is she got into some sheltered community. She was a proto-Discord
queen, and she just got free [__] all the time, and
she was like, "Wasn't gaming so nice back in the day? Wasn't
gaming like awesome when people just give you free [__]
cuz you were like the the little girl in the group? Wasn't that
awesome?"
>> Always been some issues
um in relation to misogyny, but
at one point it didn't feel so bad. Do you guys think we have
regressed as a
Uh, yes, rage baiting. There's um
>> What is it? I think it's like way better
Definitely like some or around 10 years ago things were declining
and they probably got worse and then maybe they got better.
They're definitely better now.
If for no other reason than like most most multiplayer games
will like be very aggressive about timing out or at least voice
timing out people who get
>> There's a lot of rage baiting online >> You don't
say.
>> You don't say You don't say.
You don't Oh my god. There's a lot of
>> Do you feel though that there's been rage bait for so
long that I'm I'm like tired a little bit, like I'm numb?
I actually don't get baited as much
cuz everybody knows that there's rage bait. Do you get what I
mean?
>> Do you get what I mean? >> I also think that that's
unhealthy because it leads to a level of like apathy, like we
just don't care. Like we hear bad things and we don't care because
we've been rage baited so much that we're just numb.
Like whatever. I don't even know if that's true or not. DGAF.
It's not good. >> She knows what she's doing. I just laugh.
It's just funny. All I All I can think about when I hear Poki
Dush like this is how angry people on the internet will be when
they hear it.
And I just laugh. It's just It just Listen, it brings me a little
bit of joy just knowing that it's actually going to upset people.
Like you take this seriously, you you're concerned enough about
this that you're just like going to lose it about about that.
It's just funny, man. It's just funny every time.
I do think there's some element of like I get how she was like
a Yeah, like a proto Discord queen, RuneScape, or or some game
like that where she got free items and she
That was definitely not the experience for just anybody random
on games, okay?
Sometimes you get that, sometimes somebody would just like help
you. And I do think there are people like
But for women, I do think there was definitely a
You could just prove you're a woman on voice, man. You get so
much You could You convinced me Think about how much Techtone,
we'll see about this. In fact, I have Techtone clips from today.
>> Crazy. So, let's get me back in there, boys. Like, comment,
say some dumb [__] Anyway, let's get into it. What
is Pokimane going to say this time? >> Earlier today
I bet she's going to say that she's a victim. I don't know about
what, but women are so >> Oh, that's wrong? That's totally
wrong? >> fix it >> Unless she's a victim of not
getting
But she's not even a victim of that, so >> victims. They'll
make up things that never happened just so they can feel sorry
for themselves. So, let's see how AND MAYBE I'M WRONG.
LET'S SEE HOW Pokimane is either going to be a victim or she's
going to play complain how hard her life is, or she's going to
say how poor she is, or she's going to say how evil men are.
Let's find out. It's going to be one of those four. Let's get
into it.
read this random little TikTok where I was talking about how,
hear me out, >> God, dude, everything about the way she
moves just screams pretentious [__] [laughter] [__]
>> That's so awesome.
there's a Flinters clip that I want. God, there's a Flinters
clip where he's seething at somebody and she like flips her hair
and he pauses and he just goes
[__] Like, she's literally her moving her head and
Techtone just imitated that perfectly. Just like the Literally,
the way you move The way she's moving Everything about the way
this [__] moves makes me want to just wring her neck.
Wring her neck.
Listen, I am as bitter about women as anybody in the world, but
what the [__] is this, dude?
Seriously, like how do you hate women this much that you just
have to that this is a thing? That you're seething about the
way she moves.
>> talking about how hear me out >> God, dude, everything
about the way she moves just screams pretentious
It's insane. Like I've never seen someone who thinks they're
more profound when their about is like deep as like
life lessons that you get off the Popsicle sticks that you used
to have in third grade.
>> There's no way that we're going to do projection like
this today. Is that what today is? Today's the day where we just
do insane projection? >> Like this is about as deep as
like a fortune cookie. Y'all remember when fortune cookies used
to actually said some like deep and profound [__]
Now they're like "Blue IS YOUR LUCKY COLOR TODAY." OR "LOOK both
ways BEFORE YOU CROSS THE STREET." It's like "WHAT OH OH TODAY
GOOD DAY." LIKE WHAT HAPPENED TO FORTUNE COOKIES, BRO? Like are
Americans too stupid to like understand like actually like deep
philosophical [__] now? What happened?
Did he I can't tell he's doing the same sort of like nostalgia
posting she is
her for doing it. While did. Guys, remember when remember when
video gaming as a woman used to just get treated like a goddess
and he's like, "I hate the way this [__] moves."
Remember when fortune cookies were awesome? Remember when fortune
cookies were better?
You guys remember when when video games for women were really
cool? Really really cool?
What a stupid [__] You guys remember when fortune
cookies were really cool?
Awesome. What happened? >> No, so great.
Do you guys remember like
10 15 No, 10 15 years ago? >> Yeah, that was back when
you were 40, >> I feel like 10 15 years ago if you were
a girl gaming
way she's about to about how hard it is to be a woman. Oh my
god, how do I see these things coming from 10 million miles away?
>> Uh because you watched the clip before you reacted to
it. I know. It's because
you literally watched the clip before you reacted to it. That's
why. That's how you know, right? >> How in the
women have life so
easy. Brother, if you are a three out of 10 woman, you will get
yourself a five out of a 10 man who will pay for your entire
life while you do nothing. Oh my god.
Oh my god. If you even have a female voice, you >> I I'll
just be real. I feel like Techtone's fiance is better than a
three out of 10. I'm just going to be real. I think that was
a really up thing for him to say. She is better than a three
out of 10. Come on, Techtone.
Sophia is a nice person. >> will get carried to diamond
in any game you ever play. Holy That's on the bingo card. We're
going to go back and listen to this again. Oh my god, this is
why she blocked me on >> 10 15 years ago if you were a
girl gaming online
people were actually so nice to you.
>> And how were they nice to you? By giving you tons of
money and carrying you to every rank. And now that they're not
doing that, they're mean. >> Like so nice. They treated
you so well. They would like >> Dude, I I just complained
about this with Nick and now we're watching it happen with Techtone.
It's actually so It's so [__] up. Right? The the
fake like reaction react like you are you already know exactly
what you're going to say
that you've watched the clip and you're like, "Oh, now what is
she going to say?
Now what is she going to say? This?"
It's so boring. >> gift you FREE STUFF.
>> OH MY [screaming] GOD!
THAT'S YOUR DEFINITION OF BEING KIND IS GETTING a bunch of free
OH MY GOD! IT'S LIKE I'M A I HAVE SIGHT. OH, BRO, I CAN'T BELIEVE
PEOPLE ARE SO MEAN now cuz they don't give me infinite FREE MONEY.
HOLY SH
OH MY GOD!
OH, MAN. >> IT'S actually like it has to be I assume that
it's like so obvious
to
That's where I assume that the topic is that this kind of content's
about to start falling off now. Like, you know what I mean? Like
it's just like it's like so predictable what's going to
It's just so boring
that he's he's just pre-watches then he's going to go like, "Oh,
what is she going to say now? Like this? Exact thing she says?"
>> Yeah, oh, I guess I guess sub counts low, so now she's
got to guilt-trip her chat to get more free sh Oh, dude, finally
somebody's so nice to me in chat. Oh, Elzoben, thank you for
the 20 gifted subs. Actually, thank you. Uh also, uh Soulsy,
thank you for the $20. Best slop tuber on the platform, no question.
Thank >> Dude, I I guilt my chat. I get like two subs,
okay? Guilting is not the way to >> you guys >> It's
not the way to go. >> what's great? I appreciate that.
But chat, you don't have to do that. Do I love free money? Yes.
Am I going to consider you mean cuz you didn't give me free sh
No, that's psychotic.
Buy her cookies, I guess. >> all this stuff. Do you guys
remember?
>> Oh, sorry, just a quick update on Teccy Tone, okay?
Since he's you know, had his court case and sh
I think Shamu tweeted yesterday? No, this is today, actually.
In June, Tecktony was allegedly pulling over 15,000 viewers.
Now, he's at around 3K following his court case. That's That
is an Oh, sorry. That is an 80% drop-off in viewership.
Best part about this, okay, is that Tecktony doesn't know that
Twitter views are not viewers. He did not have 15,000, okay?
He's He was wrong.
You could basically count this as like 100, 200, maybe.
But still, like 13,000 viewers, right?
12, 13,000 viewers.
Still pretty impressive,
to be honest with you. Still very impressive. And now, he doesn't
even hit 3K on YouTube alone.
Very rough, man. Very, very, very rough. >> But nowadays,
I feel like girls are a little bit scared to game online or to
use their mic or whatever. Mac, do you have something? >> Oh
my god, what if I use my microphone and people are mean? OH MY
GOD.
OH, NO.
WHAT IF SOMEBODY says something mean? Oh, you got me crying at
the club.
Bro, like these cyberbullying, bro, close the screen Turn off
the screen. It's not a big deal. It's not. Just stop being a
Holy sh
Everybody's got to baby the women, otherwise they're they're
suppressed, they're an oppressed, marginalized group. Good lord,
everybody wants >> It's so boring. It's like worse than
Fara, okay? Which I didn't think like the the gender divide could
get worse than Fara. It's like actually worse than Fara content.
You guys remember Fara content? Where it's like just literally
constantly like as much as you can exacerbating like the gender
split,
the the like gender war stuff.
This is like
This is so much worse.
It's crazy. >> Privilege. Nobody ever wants to earn. >> Her
psychic makes it bearable? That's not the only thing that makes
it bearable, but yes. Yes,
>> Anything in this world. >> Was that Was that the
OF girl? Kind of. >> Mac, thank you for subbing.
I just >> I think if you believe she was virgin, you're
probably a mark, but also
>> It's like I think about I think about >> You see
You see that? How she psychologically conditioned herself? Oh,
Oh, man. >> Not that there's anything wrong with that.
She just, you know, committed to that lie to market her OnlyFans,
which is fine. You know, I I I'm fine with that. >> They're so
mean. They don't give me free stuff anymore. But hey, chatter,
thanks for the sub. Wink.
Wink. Thank you for the sub. Man, everybody should be nice like
this guy. Holy I cannot believe people watch this. This is insane.
Where's her wedding
I thought >> Why is she doing Asian eyes? Because somehow,
I don't know how, I don't think she is technically Wajian.
She's like Moroccan and something else, but somehow she comes
out looking I swear Pokimane looks more Asian than half of the
people on Twitch.
>> What you going to >> I I think she's technically
not Asian, isn't she? She's Moroccan, yeah.
I know she's Moroccan
and Canadian, but I just I literally don't know Yeah, it's Moroccan
and white, but somehow she just looks Asian all the time. >> Where's
that? Pokimane, did you divorce yourself too? I don't blame you.
I would not want to deal with that [__] either. >> He
says I'm like, I'm not hallucinating that, right? >> Let
get on. >> Dude, I This is like when I used to watch um
Britney Simon back in the day and you hear her sing and it's
just like stupid enjoying life.
>> Take this [__]
>> That's what Tech Tone's experiencing right now. I get
it. I get it. But I don't feel I don't feel any Yeah, they're
just frolicking, just enjoying life. What the [__]
Be angry, be mad, hate your life like I >> Oh my god. >> the
thing, it makes me sad for maybe like younger women who just
got into gaming and they >> Yeah, they're they're like
they're like younger women and they're going into gaming and
they're not getting showered with infinite free money. Oh god,
men are such pigs. Ugh, disgusting. They just don't know how
to treat a woman. Where is my Bugatti and my five-star sushi
dinner that I did nothing for
exist.
And by the way, if you >> Dude, this rant is so
This rant is incredibly sad right now. >> Get paraded with
all these gifts, you know what a woman will give you back? Absolutely
nothing. And you know what will happen if you ask for something
back? Oh, that's when you get a restraining order.
>> Where are all the simps? >> think that this is
just how it's been all the time, but that's
not so much the case, I don't think. I mean, don't get me wrong,
there's always been some issues
um in relation to misogyny, but >> Don't point out that
his life is entirely funded by other people. Don't point that
out. That'd be really [__] up if you pointed that
out, okay? Why is Tech engaged again? Does his fiance have no
self-respect?
Truthfully, don't know what's going on there. His fiance
I'm trying Hmm, isn't she like 22? Yeah.
Yeah, his fiance is young, he's got money, sure. Sure, sure,
sure, sure. >> Men are now misogynistic
because they're not giving women infinite free money. Oh
>> I didn't get that impression from what she was saying.
I do think she was getting stuff and she didn't realize how good
she had it and that that's not really the regular arrangement
for most people.
But I don't get the feeling she's saying like you're misogynistic
if you don't give me infinite free [__] That's like
a lot of That's a lot of or just reading things in that aren't
>> I would like to tell you that not all women are this
insufferable. >> You didn't get that impression because
you're a long host.
Mhm.
No, but now that you say it like that, I'm starting to think
about
how a Bap impression would not be that far off from an Ela Klein
impression. You know, you know, a metaphorical long house is
how I describe it. I I just realized in my head so somehow you
just suddenly gave me a brain blast that Wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait. Hold on. What is Bap's ethnicity again? Wait,
what? Wait. No, wait. No, wait. No. >> In fact, I actually
think the overwhelming majority of women are actually just normal
people. But internet women are so
[__] entitled, it's crazy.
>> No, never.
>> Jesus. Can you believe that 3.6%
of women who are 18 to 24 have an only fans? That number is disgustingly
high. >> I mean, kudos to Takedown for getting the number
possibly right. I think he said 3.6 or something. >> believe
that 3.6%
of women who are 18 to 24 have an only
>> I could believe that. I think
that would be amongst people responding to like some internet
survey though. Like it would be it would be a number where people
are like
Like I do think that would be a what do you call it a confirmation
biased
Like you're not probably taking into account most of Africa there.
But sure, maybe most people in North America, maybe. >> That
number is disgustingly
high.
of 18 to 24.
>> Yeah, that still seems really high to me. That still
seems really really high to me. >> Bro, and it's it's skyrocketing
up. It's
That's Guys >> Well, I but I don't think it could really
be skyrocketing up.
OnlyFans is subject to market forces, okay? Once the market's
flooded, it's really not that profitable for like everybody to
get into anymore.
Right? Maybe. >> Guys guys and that that's in the United
States. So,
amount of women 18 to 24 in the US. >> There's no way he's
going to get like totally checked by AI again, is there?
There is 15 to 16 million.
I want you to look at this. Hold up.
>> Am I going to have to go check out what it is for dogs?
>> There are 15 to 16 million women 18 to 24 in the United
States. Demographic comprises roughly 12% of the total adult
population with young adults aged 18 to 24 18 to 24 totaling
just over 31
>> 18 to 24 women in the United States with an OnlyFans.
>> That seems plausible. >> That is
Who cares? Let me tell you why you care. When you grow up, when
you raise a child in this society, your daughter has a right
now a one-in-30
chance of starting an OnlyFans. There should be a one-in-1
billion. Better yet, a 0% chance that happens. The fact that
young women are seeing becoming an Only
>> I mean, it depends on what they do. I
I don't know. >> Like prostitute.
>> I personally don't think OnlyFans is good. So, like
it's like really hard for me to argue for it. I really don't
like Only Fans. I don't like like what it does to the way people
view So, I don't like a lot of the stuff with like on the internet.
But, at the same time, if you're like Sophie Rain's father, aren't
you like way more psyched that that she didn't do like
and she made like tens of billions of dollars already. Like she's
set for life. She's done.
Yeah, she had a short but like
Okay, she won, right?
Now, if your if your daughter was doing Only Fans and she didn't
make any money, that would be kind of rough. That would be shitty.
>> as a viable career option when they turn 18 is disgusting.
That's crazy.
crazy. Gone are the days where people actually want respectable
careers.
>> Didn't Pink She didn't Teccy Tone convince Pink She
to do Only Fans? I actually don't know if that's true. Is that
something we know?
I actually don't know if that's true. That would be kind of rough
for the arguments he's making right now. Yes, that's true. Oh,
well.
I mean classic Teccy Tone, really. Classic Teccy Tone. I couldn't
remember So, that was something I thought I remembered, but I
didn't know for sure. It seems like we've got an overwhelming
majority of
>> This is where listening to
the advice that Asmongold gets you that there's no reason to
have any pride or honor. And it's unfortunate as it is because
women who do throw away their honor and their pride and their
self-respect will be rewarded infinitely. And it's a shame. It's
a shame. It's a [__] shame. Bring back the brig.
True.
>> At one point it didn't feel so bad. >> Pokimane,
if you were to stop saying dumb [__] all the time,
you would have the easiest life possible.
Because I promise you there are many girl By the way, she looks
dumb as [__] here. Not as dumb as me though. But
that being said, I don't care. My audience isn't here for my
looks, where Pokimane entirely is. If you were to just shut your
mouth and go live and just smile and laugh at jokes, you would
have five
>> Yeah, you stupid [__] Don't you know that
the only thing you're good for is to like sit there and just
look pretty?
Don't you know that that's what you're good for? You're just
like a pretty just sit there and look pretty, okay? Don't give
me your opinion.
Uh I don't I'm not going to give a [__] about it.
I'm just going >> is the reality. Because there is so many
women who are their entire gimmicks are just dumb plastic bimbos
that say nothing and chat will just have them up because they
need company who get thousands of viewers very easily, right?
>> At least there's something going on there that makes
sense.
I trust me. People are way better if they go into the world and
they're just like sappy for Pokimane, okay? They were simps for
Pokimane. They have a way better shot in the world than if they
fell into whatever trap makes you like be be like concerned for
Techtone and his stupid self-victimization.
The people who like are stuck in Techtone's web are infinitely
worse off in life than any any Pokimane tier five
oiler, okay?
Whoever are the people supporting this guy, those are the people
truly in >> Your biggest enemy is the fact that you want
to voice your own stupidest opinions and that's the reality.
I have never seen a Poki clip where it wasn't her saying the
most beyond
the most beyond relatable, the most out of touch I've ever seen
in my entire life. Bro,
went to a man's house and doxxed him and she still has a career.
Hold on.
The Are you talking? What is that related to? I mean, I can think
of other people who've done some similar things, okay? She Wait,
doxing and they still have a career? What?
No. I've never heard of this before. IT MUST BE BECAUSE she's
an attractive woman. That's the only That's the only possible
explanation, guys. Someone's just doxing people and they still
have a career?
No shot. >> Right. Do you want to see how many views she
gets still?
I actually haven't checked this in a very long time. S- S- S-
Sniperwolf. Bro, bro. Sniperwolf
every day is still getting hundreds of thousands of >> Oh,
so she like totally fell off. She like cataclysmically fell off
then. That's Wasn't Weren't these videos like 3 million, 2 million?
And now they're only like 200,000.
That's like a 10x fall off, right?
And this woman went to a man's house live
to dox him and attempt to get him killed. And do you want to
know why? That's because Sniperwolf looks like a stupid bimbo
who is the alive version of a blow-up doll.
All you have to do is just smile and giggle at whatever >> Isn't
Sniperwolf the one who like doesn't shower ever, right? Whose
hair is like totally like matted and gross and she just wears
wigs?
Is that Am I thinking of the right person? I'm I'm almost positive.
Was it uh Nerd City who did a video on her? And all of that was
in there about how she like doesn't shower, she like her hair
is super crusty and gross. She just wears wigs.
She basically got like no hair. >> ever's on the screen
and you will have a hundreds thousands of viewers. It doesn't
matter. I like I like I like like Guys, I mean this woman is
publicly confirmed
going to SOMEONE'S HOUSE, LIVE ON STREAM, BECAUSE THEY DISAGREED
WITH HER ON THE INTERNET, TO DOX THEM, TO GET PEOPLE to try to
kill that person.
And she >> Wait, did um I think she went to the guy's house
or something, but did she show like she showed like his street
name or something, right?
Is that what it was? Jacksfilms guy? Did she show his street
name as she went >> has 35 million subscribers, and she
gets hundreds of thousands of views every single [__]
day.
Basically, the reason she um she got away with that was because
she made them so much money.
If she was like 10 If she was where she is now, I I do believe
she'd have fallen
She'd have gotten banned or something.
Yeah, I I think basically it was just the amount of money she
was making,
That that allowed her to keep her I think basically anybody else
gets nuked for that. >> I think. >> 36
million views, meaning that she's making well over 120,000
off of YouTube alone.
Dude, say allegedly. Am I crazy or did that not happen? Am I
misremembering this? Did she not do that to [__]
>> Pretty sure she did. >> even think I HAVE TO SAY
ALLEGEDLY. Is that not a thing that was confirmed to have happened?
She 100%
did that [__] online.
She did, she did, she did, she did that [__] she
did it. You know what? Just in case, allegedly.
Uh maybe she was just doxing him for
>> Oh, I think the reason she got away with it was that
he has his address listed on Google Business or some [__]
Hey, it's still weird, but okay, maybe. >> maybe she was
just doxing him so that way people might prank him to give him
pizza parties. You're right. You're right. Oh, oh, it's allegedly.
Yeah. All right.
Yeah, yeah, may maybe it was just a little joke. All right, cool.
Anyways, let's get You know what? Why don't Why don't we grok
this [__]
Let's grok it. Super grok it, really? Did Sniperwolf
publicly doxx Jackfilms?
Let's just double-check. But, you know, let me just check.
Yes, Sniperwolf, Alia Shelesh, publicly posted that revealed
the location of Jackfilms' home, which was widely accused and
reported as doxxing. >> Did this guy This guy leans on
grok for everything,
all the time. He just literally, if he has any dispute with his
chat, he just immediately groks.
If you Snapchat, sorry. If you Oh my >> Instagram story,
5 minutes away from her house, shared videos outside of his home.
Guys,
I'm sorry.
And she still has a channel getting millions of views because
that's how easy it is to be a woman in 2026
to where you can do this disgusting ass
and there will be no punishment for it. There will be none. There
will be no punishment for it. And by the way, >> Oh my
god, I wonder what tech grok says about Techtone's case.
Wait, hold on. This might show
>> No. You guys don't get to see my whole grok history.
Nope. Nope. You don't get to. No, no, no, no, no, no, no. Okay,
hold on. Um I want to
call Techtone a
he be able to sue me?
What about if I use the moniker
the moniker
Seems like it's going that direction. Now, hold on. I'm going
to have to ask a clarifying question here cuz it seems like it's
just going to say, "Well, if you call somebody a that could be
defamation per se."
>> Oh, lacks a criminal conviction. Geez, there's agents
going and everything. This is whole bunch of things happening
here. Jesus. Uh-oh.
It seems as though being prevalent could affect new claims
is widely used online. Oh, but whether he'd win is another story.
It's an uphill battle for him and this isn't legal advice. I'm
not a lawyer. Here's a breakdown based on US LAW. LET'S GO. He
technically could sue me, but it'd be an uphill battle for him.
Let's go. Let's
go. Thank you, Grok. The moniker This is straight-up wordplay
implying he's a So, the same definition analysis applies. It's
not magically safer just because it's a nickname. It's already
widely used online, Reddit, X, Twitter, drama channels, even
referenced by other creators like Hasan. Tech Tone himself has
leaned into the vibrant joke post ruling. Courts sometimes protect
nicknames, parody, or hyperbole in public feuds as opinion rather
than literal fact, especially on a hot
Still risky if you use it in a context that clearly accuses him
of rape, i.e., Rape Tone did X. It could be argued as a fair
comment on public events, but he could sue anyway. Practical
realities. I don't know.
Looks unlikely if you're just repeating or riffing on the public
civil case and community nickname. Let's go. That's it. Don't
do it. No, I'm going to I'm going to ignore that part. I'm going
to ignore that part. Sounds like he won't be able to sue me for
it. All right, we're good.
For the hundreds of women that get caught doing this horrible
behavior
and still receive no punishment, there's even more women who
got away with the
And that's what's disgusting
is the amount of women who got away with the [__]
But the good news is the normal man is waking up and they're
realizing how [__] >> I would never play League
of Legends. I will never play League of Legends in my entire
life.
I honestly you could try to throw me a I think I would turn down
a $10,000 donation to play League of Legends. I'm not even joking.
On principle. My principles are worth more than that. A $100,000
you could probably break me
Be between 10 and 100. I think I could turn down 10. And I just
say no, I'm not installing that. I don't give a
I'm pretty confident I could turn down 10 pretty easily. >> society.
And not only is it men, it's other women tired of other women
who are making it hard
>> Uh been tried, Evil Morty J R X. Never >> for
them to just exist. And if you want to know why the space has
gotten worse for women online, Poki, it's because of like you.
People like you, entitled,
self-righteous douchebags
who just think their own [__] smells like roses to
where it's going to make OTHER MEN HATE WOMEN WHO HAVE DONE
BUT NOTHING WRONG. >> Because people like you get a megaphone.
It's pathetic.
>> There'd definitely be some people who would pay for
that. Okay. For sure.
>> This is a 1-minute clip that I've been reacting to for
16 minutes. Holy Let's get going. >> There's a lot of rage
baiting online >> There's no way that what you're saying
is actually not rage bait. If you genuinely think that women
have it hard cuz they're no longer getting free money and gifts.
>> All right, guys. After you're yelling at her for an
hour, now he's saying she's rage baiting. Well,
it's it's just like weakness. You know she's rage baiting, but
you still have to rage out about it. It's just weakness. It's
a lack of self-control,
That's all it is.
One second. >> All right.
This This is what you see online.
All right. This is what you see online.
This is what you see after she takes a
All right. >> Again, I
I genuinely don't know.
For Tectone, I know this isn't true. My my thoughts whenever
somebody makes this argument is like, have you ever woken up
next to like a woman before
your entire life?
It's like the kind of comparison somebody makes if they're just
like, "Oh my god, I you have no idea what like makeup looks like.
You've no idea what women look like when they're like getting
ready to go to bed." Which is like sad. It's sad when people
out themselves like this. I think Tectone's just farming anyway,
right? She still is pretty, but definitely less wajan. Uh I just
try not to like I don't need to simp for how she looks now. It's
just like, "Hey, that's how people look without makeup on." That's
literally That's literally what it looks like, man. I don't know
what to tell you. People who like do this comparison, it's like,
"Yeah, the rest of us knew." Are you Are you good? Did Did you
not know this? It's like a revelation to some people. It's like,
"Hey,
bro, all women don't look like that without makeup?" No, most
of them look significantly worse without makeup, blank. Thank
you. You're right. Hold on. Blank just wanted to let me know
that all women don't look like that without makeup. Yes, most
women look significantly worse than that without makeup. Yes.
Pokimane is still probably a fairly attractive woman without
the makeup on.
She's still like upper echelon in terms of looks without the
makeup on. Yes.
>> Keep going. >> after one shower.
Online
after one shower, okay? So, let's just be real.
What you should say is Pokimane is really good at makeup, okay?
>> She is. >> You should say, "Wow, Pokimane, you're
very good at makeup. That's very
All right? This chick's 35, by the way. >> That's upper
for Canada, by the way. No, it's not, dude.
You guys are like hyper coping.
let's continue. Still would, brother. Okay, do whatever the [__]
you want. All I'm saying is there's a very big difference between
being beautiful
and being good at makeup. There's a >> Huh. Okay, the one
thing nobody's ever said about Canada is that there aren't beautiful
women here. So, everybody who's like, "Oh, you're Canadian."
That makes Shut up. Literally, the only thing we have going for
us is the number of hot girls that are here, okay? You can't
take that away. It's always going to be there. It's just a fact,
okay? >> Huge difference. There's a very big difference
between being beautiful and buying a $40,000 pair of getting
liposuction
every 3 months because your fat ass can't stop eating getting
lip filler every month getting buccal fat surgery because your
face is ugly and then you made it even worse using five AI filters
on >> What? Is he just in He's just inventing a woman to
be mad at now?
He's going to invent a woman to be mad at now? Canada know for
having hot women? Yeah, the woman from Vikings or so the woman
who's in Vikings is here. She's Canadian. What's her name? The
Lagertha actor actress, okay?
That's just
You know who I'm talking about? >> photo and every Catherine
Winnick >> Yeah, Catherine Winnick. >> every video
that you ever exist >> She's like 45, by the way. She's
old as
That's some crazy [__] >> And then putting
on $600 worth of product every single time you go live. Now,
you can call me a jackass, but you can't call me wrong. All right?
Just five true.
Yep. All right. Anyways, so when can we see you with makeup?
Please answer. I'm not going to lie, bro. I look kind of hot
with makeup. I'm I'm not going to lie, bro. Hold up. Let's see
if I can find this.
>> Uh-huh. Okay, I think that's about it for the Tectone
thing. I'm sure I could go to the Pokimane like quote tweets
and find a million people seething about it.
I just Yeah, basically
getting your cortisol spiked by Pokimane in any way is
low IQ.
You're being filtered. It's very sad. Giving her exactly what
she wants.
Right? Just chill.
Keep it pushing. Everything's going to be fine, okay? Everything
is going to be fine. I just came across your Anisa miss. What
the What does this mean? The
Fuentes misogyny is so much better. Oh god, what is this going
to be? Uh-oh.
Del Groyp tweet. What is this? What is this? What is this?
Fuentes rips into women for making the same dumb smug faces.
And look at how smug she is. Look at how smug her face is. Look
at her. Look at this face. Only women are capable of making faces
like that. You know what I'm talking about? That's not true.
I bet you Fuentes could make that face. What is it about their
faces that they can contort them? It's something about women
that's going on lately. And I don't know what you call it. I
don't know I can't put my finger on it, but they make these like
It's like insincerity
combined with contorting their faces in this emotive
It's a It's just To be clear, it is called a smile. I He's describing
a smile right now. And women these days, they're always making
faces and I want to >> to you Like I really just want to
blast them in the face. When I see them making faces, like when
I'm watching Tik Tok and a woman's telling like an elaborate
story, there's all Suddenly, women are doing these gesticulations.
They're doing this, they're doing claws.
Every story they're doing this, they're going
>> He does gesticulation all the time. >> They're
doing claws, they're doing this and they're doing these crazy
faces. Is that new?
I feel like that's not normal. I feel like my grandmother doesn't
make faces >> Look at this Look at her gesticulate while
he speaks. >> My mother doesn't make faces like that. It's
like a Gen Z female thing. And I don't know where they're getting
that, I don't know what that is, but it's like they're on this
level of it's like smugness
and something like sarcasm or irony and they can twerk their
faces doing these gesticulations
and I want to grab both their wrists with my hands.
And I just want to stop When they start doing the faces, not
actually, I'm not a violent person, but I just can't do it anymore
with the faces. I don't know what that is.
>> So what he said this is a
What is it? This is what I When I see her make this stupid smug
face, I just want to just want to just want to [__]
can't just going the face.
Make the stupid smug face. >> This I don't know what you
call it and I hate it, but she's making this smug face. It's
like, "Hey, you're in a trash bag." Like >> you're sitting
there in a trash bag. Would it be more authentic if it was filled
with actual trash? Like let me dump some spaghetti and some banana
peels and some coffee grounds and let me throw in some uh used
tissues. Like would that make it more And And let's put that
on you and then make a smug face and take a selfie making a stupid
face and say, "Look, guys, we're garbage. We're garbage. Look,
I did the thing." Cuz that's what Women love that kind of stuff.
Women love to put on a stupid outfit and they like to think about
accessories and nails and then they love to take the dumbest
picture you've ever seen making the most obnoxious facial expression
in the most obnoxious pose you've ever seen. Women >> Jesus,
this guy's really going off. I Uh I just had to check my phone
for a second. This guy's still going This guy's still talking
about it. >> Women will like What What is it the way that
women pose, the way they like bend their knees, or they like
put their ass >> This is so much funnier when you get hyper-specific
about things. That makes it so much funnier, okay? If you want
to be an incel, don't just generally rage at women with the worst
tropes, the most obvious overused tropes. Get very specific.
Talk about how they set their legs for photos. Yes. That's what
you need to do. Then it can be funny again. >> ass out.
It makes me just want to, you know, they'll make the dumbest
face, make the stupid pose in a stupid outfit with the selfie,
and they live for that [__] They live for it. They
live for that. Women exist. Their function is to harvest or organic
matter and turn it into Instagram photographs to tr- to
the same way that a spider weaves a web, the same way that a
beaver builds a dam, a female will create
>> I'm a machine THAT TAKES IN CALORIES AND PUTS OUT SELFIES.
Let's go.
>> ass out. They'll create an outfit, they'll create a
pose
to take a picture and to edit the picture and post it on on media.
That is what they exist to do. That is what their function is.
Wow.
See, Tecto, that's how you do misogyny,
That's how you do misogyny, just to be
I'm pretty sure
weirdly, Tecto should be good at misogyny because
certainly, while Nick may not be quite up to snuff, Nick may
be the second most scared of out of all content creators. Not
quite at Tecto levels, but Nick is also terrified of So, there
must I thought there was something there that made you a good
incel. Apparently not.
You hate to see it.
All right. Okay.
continue. I Oh, [__] >> All right. >> Oh,
we're not done. >> Let Let's just be real, man. Like, you
know, let's just let's just keep a [__] Hold up.
>> No filters,
just good lighting, I would give myself at least a 7.5 out of
10 here.
>> Dude, he's sticking his his neck out really badly to
give the impression of a
>> No hair, no makeup, no filters, some good lighting,
sure, I would give myself a 7 and 1/2. I'm not going to lie,
I would. I would. I absolutely would. Right? It is what it is.
It is what it
>> He's got He's got hardcore down lighting there. That's
It's pretty easy to look good with down lighting like that. >> we're
back at it. Let's get into it. Roids? Well, not anymore. All
right, we're back to it.
>> You see his delts back in that? I'm not sure if he's
Roids? Well, >> See his delts? They're massive. That's
always a big indicator, right? >> Not anymore. All right,
we're back to >> There's a lot of rage baiting online
I do feel though that there's been rage bait for so long that
I'm I'm like tired a little bit. Like I'm numb.
>> Bro, you literally called your own audience poor if
they didn't buy your cookies. How are you one to complain about
rage-bait at all? Holy
Also, she had What a Oh my god. Oh my
>> She won so hard again. Dude, he like he took all this
time to calm down. He looked at his own picture of him after
working out and she just instantly instantly spiked his cortisol
again.
She just got him again.
Dude, she just This guy literally paused. He walked away. He
got his like he got his cortisol back down, okay? He looked at
it. Boom, instant spike. Why do people rage-bait? I just don't
get it. It's like maybe I'm just a little numb to the rage-bait
cuz I've seen it so much. >> Cuz I'll just be [__]
pissed. >> Like I'm about to rip my brainstem out. Holy
sh This is the most performative woman on the entire internet.
She bought a stack of books >> as just >> I I seriously
Is Poki's content is somehow perfectly engineered to trigger
insecure dudes? It's wild. That's like it. It's like I barely
even listen to what Poki says. Sorry, Poki. It's just the way
it is, okay? But I just I just wait I just know I'm going to
see some other people lose their absolute sh over whatever she
just said, okay? Every single time. It's
Oh my
god. Bro, I know this [__] can't even read. Did you
guys even notice this [__] in the back left? Dude,
she wants to seem so knowledgeable. >> It's insane. Oh
my >> Oh, he get he get almost spike my he get almost spike
my cortisol there as the guy with Meditations and Marcus Aurelius
in the background. Yeah. He get almost Listen, I'm a little I'm
I'm you know
I'm keeping it chill, okay? We're keeping it leisurely. It's
fine. We're all good over here. You can't spot You can't get
me to freak out over something like that, okay? >> My god.
Oh >> But one could point out the hypocrisy >> god.
I'm going to I'm tweaking, bro. I'm This is some psychotic [__]
bro. This is some This is psychotic [__] >> I
actually don't get baited as much
cuz everybody knows that there's rage bait. Do you get what I
mean?
But that's I also think that that's
But that's I also think that that's unhealthy because it leads
to a level of like apathy. Like we just don't care. Like we hear
bad things and we don't care because we've been rage baited so
much that we're just not
Like whatever. I don't even know if that's true or not. >> I
will never be numb to how the things that come out of Pokimane's
mouth are.
>> I'll never be numb to how the things that come out of
Pokimane's mouth are. >> that we're just not
>> Like whatever. I don't even know if that's true or >> Cool.
Cool. >> I will never be numb to how the things that come
out of Pokimane's mouth are.
Besides the things that go into her mouth, which is usually her
neighbor. >> D gaf? >> Okay. Jesus.
>> It's not a good >> Jesus.
That >> He's always got to include that element there,
doesn't he?
First Etika, now Poki. What the hell? >> a lot to unpack,
guys. That was just a lot to unpack.
Good god. I don't know. WestJet needs to get on that [__]